ja ja wo seit madonna ende haus fresh
aus eurem kinderzimmer mit dem neuesten
trick hier am start denn wir wollen
kuchen warten also backe backe kuchen
der bäcker hat gerufen wer möchte kuchen
machen der muss haben sieben sagt meyer
und schmal und sei milch und mehl und
ihr wissen
safran macht den kuchen geht schiebt
offen nein hallo leute jetzt wieder
einmal wandel und willkommen zu einer
neuen folge wie schmeckt und heute
machen wir endlich den backe backe
kuchen jetzt richtig wünscht jetzt kommt
er dieses lied kennt eigentlich jedes
kind weil wir das alle im kindergarten
singen mussten oder unsere eltern
wollten pädagogisch wertvoll sein und
haben es mit uns gesungen
ich habe mir noch nie gedanken über den
text gemacht sieben zutaten für einen
kunden statt - sind wenig zu sein
besonders weil nichts in diesem rezept
an backpulver natron irgendwas damit der
kunde hat auch flüssig wird beschrieben
wird hat vielleicht den zaun kaputt
gemacht backpulver reimt sich halt nicht
so viel worauf ranzig backpulver montani
elzie brainstorm mit bälle zu werden
wäre klar
deswegen ist er auch hinter der kamera
aber viel über diesen song heraus
gefunden und zwar stammt er aus
mindestens 1840 in sachsen thüringen wie
der thüringische nordthüringen also
solange singt man den schon da wurde da
irgendwie aufgezeichnet ich habe aber
auch gelesen natürlich auch wikipedia
dass er auch schon 1600 irgendwas in
einer alte deutsche reform gesungen
wurde also dieser song ist mega und ich
finde den hintergrund dieses lieds noch
ganz spannend denn es wird vermutet dass
der becker früher gerufen hat als sein
ofen noch restwärme hatte also als er
sein ganzes brot gebacken hat und dann
hat er gerufen und
hast du gesagt leute ihr könnt euren
kuchen hier im ofen backen denn ich habe
hier noch ein bisschen wärme also beide
backen kuchen der bäcker hat gerufen
notepad da ist keine mengenangaben gibt
macht mir das einfach so ein bisschen
freistaats also sollen wir uns nach der
reihenfolge hätten einen stundenlohn
enden hier dem rezept wird ja nach der
hat mein folge guter und schmalz oder
schmalz sieht einfach aus
die noch fertige version von
butterschmalz klingt auch so was wie
vaseline ohne die noch kleinere version
von bremen
[Musik]
reihenfolge sind schlau wäre und schmalz
zucker und seit sich und mir ja wir
machen es ja und schmeißt dreier fällt
mir noch ein klassisches kinder nicht
einfach früher wäre sagte hundekacke
donald
gehen wir einmal unsere jungs das heißt
jetzt scheiße
das hätten wir fürs kochbuch nehmen
sollen dass es auch sie wie honig heiße
motor immer gut ob sich das jetzt hier
im hof lösen 30 sekunden später wir
haben uns entschieden die kitchenaid
1850 zu nehmen und damit zu hören
[Musik]
na und schmalz zucker und salz zucker
und sagte schon das wird nichts
[Musik]
so lassen sich folglich und gut aus
dann suchen
damit wasser
also leute ich bin absolut begeistert
den teig sieht gar nicht so scheiße aus
so ok wird müssen flüssig
obwohl also kommt sonst so cremig 5
knoten doch kuchen knetet man nicht ich
werde das alles kameramann weist es
[Musik]
aber jetzt natürlich weiß jedes kind
safran noch die zeit auch den gehen und
jeder steht auch umgehen kuchen
weißt du was gehe heißt da hüpft geil
geil geil heißt geld im althochdeutschen
beziehungsweise im duden steht
landschaft wird also wahrscheinlich
einige jede landschaft klima wirbel in
berlin würde jede landschaft den ist
nicht jede landschaft das rote gold drei
euro für das hier das ist aber auch ganz
interessant eigentlich ne ich habe noch
nie im kuchen gegessen wo safran drinnen
leute das könnte hier eigentlich mega
das gerade rezept werden wo habt ihr
schonmal safran kuchen gegessen ich habe
ja noch diese safranfäden von dem game
of thrones video dachte aber dass ich
pulver besser eignet für kuchen ja wir
machen jetzt mal den kuchen geben
geil geil hat aber auch so einen starken
geruch
es fängt schon an der kopie wird also
das pulver gibt nicht so viel ab und
bevor ich da jetzt die ganze pampe
reinmache versuche ich das einmal mit
den fäden haben wir doch unser rotes
gold leute safran so nah kommt leute
gibt ein geiles gefühl
probieren wir deine technik nicht
einfach ein bisschen wasser also ja
stimmt das schon gemacht
wissen wird dazu leck mich am arsch die
das kainsmal die normale persischen
reifen drauf kann man bei zuviel safran
irgendwie okay
safran macht den kuchen gehe moody's
crazy er ist auf jeden fall schon gela
als vorher ist dass davon
ich habe mir gesagt haben recht ich
finde das richtig relativ neue tracht
gekleidet trat gut und ihr euch auch
außenverteidiger kühlschrank der
kühlschrank auf er steht hinter dieser
wie schnell tafeln mein kochbuch
bestellt euch trick 17
[Musik]
naja für den rand nehmen wir noch ein
bisschen schmeiße ich gehe geworden dass
dialekte
ich wollte die sache frau die partie
[Musik]
das passt schon dass man so was wir auf
keinen fall tun haben wir das
luftbläschen werden glücklich aus blogs
und den damit in den backofen ich hoffe
er wird was sehen wir später der kuchen
ist gel oder war ein bisschen zu lange
drin aber eigentlich sind der mega gut
aus das ist jetzt peinlich
[Musik]
also sieht auf jeden fall nicht so
schlimm aus wie es mir vorgestellt habe
und jetzt lassen wir den kuchen kühlen
und dann können wir endlich probiere
irgendwann später kleiner bar ist jetzt
hier abgekühlt wir verlieren unseren
abgetönten natürlich mit safran denn das
macht den schönen gehen falls ich das
rezept so einfach ist noch andere tolle
rezepte finden sich in einem kochbuch
nicht merkt wie schmeckt der
beschreibung sind wir bereit ist
und jetzt stellen uns natürlich wieder
eine analytics frage wie schmeckt der
kuchen aus backe backe kuchen
einer sagt zuerst da ist zuviel safran
drin das definitiv zu wenig vorhanden
ist da frank künftig also ganz ehrlich
der schmeckt so wie man 1800 und kuchen
gebacken hätte ohne witz genau so stellt
man sich gebäck vor was so 200 jahre alt
ist konsistent und so ist schon alles
richtig so wie safran geschmack safran
ein sehr spezielles aroma und sollte
sehr vorsichtig dosiert werden sagt man
schmeckt leicht bitter aromatisch zu
viel des guten verursacht einen leicht
medizinischen metallischen geschmack der
amerikaner hat das würde ich auch sein
wir haben da war auch echt zu viel
reingepackt gut saffer macht bei den
kuchen geht aber man sollte auch damit
nicht übertreiben ich habe natürlich wie
immer euch hat folge gefallen und wenn
ja dann zeigt es mir unbedingt mit dem
daumen nach oben
ihr auftritt folgt mir auf cq5 mir auf
twitter folgt mir auf instagram sind da
habe ich seit kurzem einen haken hat man
muss wohl ein kochbuch erst schreiben um
auf instagram blauen haken zu bringen
dankeschön immer klappen und abonniert
diesen kanal
da passt nichts weiteres und bewegen uns
dann beim backen kuchen der bäcker
[Musik]